j'ai été ensemble durant au met ses
foucades disent que vous avez été
ensemble et c'est son problème elle a
rêvé et les terrifiants de mensonges
ben oui vous avez tant couple bat de en
1983 c'est lui qui m'a draguée bien sûr
et puis en plus il parle pas de comment
il me taper sur la gueule parce qu'une
baptême taper il vous attaques fusent et
bien sûr j'ai plein de témoin les années
80 y en a pas un qui veut travailler
avec lui en tournée j'ai perdu un bébé
de lui et c'est lui qui m'a emmené à
l'hôpital quand j'ai fait la fausse
couche donc il via qu'est-ce qui
viennent dire et il raconte n'importe
quoi ce mec là
alors déjà il nie tout il était 17
heures marié avec une femme ce monsieur
est ni déjà toute forme de relation avec
vous alors que vous vous dites que vous
avez pas pardon coucher des centaines de
fois avec lui et que vous êtes sortis
ensemble longtemps c'est peut-être des
milliers
depuis 1983 nous étions à 100 étaient
ensemble oui mais on vivait pas ensemble
dans ce voyage est sur le toit vers
l'asie je faisais des galas et on se
retrouvait les saoudiens est ce que vous
étiez amoureuse oui j'étais très
amoureuse cet homme là d'où l'idée du
duo d'ailleurs et puis je lave où
j'étais amoureuse et ça vous dérange et
a du coup qui sortent pas qu'ils restent
avec sa femme pendant 17 ans et d'être
la maîtresse on va dire mais non non non
c'est quand on était ensemble il a connu
sa femme après ouais d'accord oui oui
c'est moi qui ai connu mon mari pendant
17 ans après lui en fait j'étais avec
lui en 84 83 84 85 et
185 je l'ait quittée parce que j'en
pouvais plus je faisais 42 kg et
régulièrement j'avais les yeux au beurre
noir est alors lui dit que c'est vous
que médicalement vous me donnez rien
c'est moi qui ai fait la chanson c'est
pas lui c'est vous qui l'avez fait mais
bien sûr que dans l'interview votre
jardin de luxe lui aussi dit que c'est
faux et vous et vous imposer partout
parce que vous étiez mauvaise c'est ce
qu'il dit bien mais ça là une idiotie
avéré pervers narcissique il raconte
n'importe quoi comme ça les arrange eux
et vous savez quoi à la limite je veux
dire l'artistique pour moi c'est pas ce
qui est le plus important c'est ce que
vous avez dit vous dit le plus grave
c'est qu'il me frappait
vous dites même qu'une fois et vous êtes
tellement frappé les pompiers sont venus
nous chercher vous avez des yeux au
beurre noir et que votre frange quand
vous étiez sur les sur les plateaux télé
elle servait à cacher des bleus c'est
vrai ça c'était surtout le fond de teint
pour cacher les yeux au beurre noir un
jour ian ici m'a donné un coup de tête
entre les deux yeux et j'ai eu les yeux
au beurre noir pendant quinze jours
j'étais dans la tournée de michel leeb
et puis après comme il a vu que j'avais
les yeux au beurre noir il me donnait
des coups de tête dans la tête pour pas
que ça se voit donc au bout d'un moment
ça ça s'est arrêté parce qu'il ya des
gens qui l'ont arrêté et puis j'ai
maigri maigri maigri maigri je suis
tombée enceinte sans le savoir et un
jour à l'hôtel on est en dormait tous
les deux j'ai fait une fausse couche il
m'a laissé crever la nuit à l'hôtel et
lendemain matin comme j'étais à moitié
morte mais il m'a emmené à l'hôpital de
cannes il m'a jetée aux urgences il a
dit prenez moi ce paquet j'en ai marre
et voilà et c'est la stricte vérité et
il ya des témoins mais je vais pas
inventer une chose pareille c'est là une
femme ne peut pas inventer qu'elle a été
battue et quel hacker la une fait une
fausse couche c'est vrai que cet
homme-là gelé mais bon maintenant je
m'aperçois en analysant que c'était très
sexuel c'est pour ça quand il dit qui
m'a jamais touchée alors je voulais vous
dire il s'appelle joseph je m'appelle
marie on a ce que bah oui ils ont eu un
enfant jésus qui était du saint-esprit
donc lui c'est pareil donc je m'appelle
tous lawn je m'appelle marines et
louis-joseph ça lui va bien c'est fou
c'est pétain en tête mais j'ai gardé sa
37 ans parce que le dio c'était toute ma
vie j'ai travaillé tellement d'années
pour réussir c'est une phase bécaud m'a
demandé de faire c'est cette chanson là
qui est devenue la face à très fier très
heureuse duo très amoureuse de peter
mais c'est pour ça que les trois scènes
nous ont aimés pendant ces 7 3 ans
vraiment vous étiez ensemble est
amoureuse qu'est ce que vous vous disiez
camp quand ils vous frappent et kanté
vous insulter comme vous faisait une
fausse couche est ce que comme beaucoup
de femmes battues vous disiez je le
mérite c'est normal mais non non c'est
pas ça c'est que j'étais sous contrat
donc je pouvais pas bouger c'était le
rêve de ma vie ce duo de réussir les
producteurs le voyait mais les
producteurs y êtes au courant mais eux
les producteurs y voyait que silvio
s'arrêtait y avait plus de vent qui
avaient péri en était promis au top 5
ans on en a vendu 47 milles vente disque
par jour vous allez arrêter ça et ben
non c'est toute ma carrière moi j'ai
travaillé des années pour y arriver et
en plus c'est une chanson à moi et et
vos amis et vos proches du cou qui en
étaient témoins oui ce qui vous ont aidé
est ce qu'ils ont voulu faire ni où la
famille énormément certains amis mais
l'art il a encouragé à peut-être aller
porter plainte ou réagir plus fort ici
mais moi je voulais pas parce que je
voulais que le duo continue que le
public ne sachant ni les alarmes et
sharon elle selon vous avez vous avez
vous dit vous dites que vous avez des
témoins beaucoup de témoins j'ai lui nie
toute l'interview résister cette seule
compétence des mentos est monté lui nie
tout vous dites que vous avez des
témoins oui vous avez des témoins
notamment michel leeb ou dit michel leeb
en tournée j'ai eu sa femme il ya deux
jours et toute façon je ne pense pas que
qui que ce soit viendra t me chalié vous
êtes l'a vu en train de vous frapper un
nom lui m'a pas vu c'est un photographe
doc et magazines qui étaient là que je
ne nommerai pas mais qui à mon avis ne
viendra pas témoigner mais c'est pas le
problème toute façon on voyait bien les
musiciens il voyait bien de michel leeb
que j'avais les yeux au beurre noir sur
scène je m'étais sa de fond de teint
vous avez fait des tournées après oui
oui après par le passé vous avez fait la
tournée star 80 avec olivier kieffer que
je salue au nom justement le on a fait
michel drucker ouais euh là trois mois
avant la tournée au lancement du star 80
le premier la star 80 j'ai eu le premier
rôle féminin et holiday killer qui
produisait voilà et olivier kieffer qui
produisait et thomas langmann oui non
c'était coco de cheyenne premier pardon
tous les deux et donc on était dans la
tournée avec peter et juste au moment où
on allait faire en direct
les émissions de télévision il me dit
j'arrête le duo tira pas dans la tournée
tir à bout cellphone des chevaux ça te
fera maigrir c'est la dernière fois ce
qui m'a dit et puis on se parle plus
mais d'ailleurs vous m'avez confié
qu'ils vous il vous prenait même un
pourcentage de vos cachets oui ça qui
m'a dit si tu veux faire la tournée rfm
party 80 en 2009 il m'a dit tu me donnes
15 % parce que je viendrais pas chanter
j'ai pas besoin de ça pour vivre toi tu
en as besoin je venais de me séparer
d'avec mon mari j'avais ma fille a élevé
et il m'a pris 15 % sur toute la tournée
sloan je sais oui oui c'est aberrant que
j'ai rien dis non c'est pas je ne vais
pas du tout ça quand villa choses comme
il faut comme mais il la vit ça me ça me
fait ça me fait de la peine en fait est
que je sais ce que je veux dire c'est
que quand quand tout ça je comprends
très bien que parfois il faut manger
subir des choses horribles
quand tout ça s'est arrêté qui a pu lui
a tourné tout ça est quelque part vous
étiez libre peut-être financièrement
dans la merde mais libre à ce moment là
pourquoi vous n'allez pas porter plainte
pas parce que je voulais continuer à
laisser la magie sur ce titre là et j'ai
bien fait j'ai bien fait et dans ma tête
je ne tousse à moi j'étais avec mon mari
et puis j'avais ma malbosc était là
shazia bête que ça votre mari comme mon
mari le savez bien sûr est ce que vous
étiez quand même chacun de mariée de
votre côté et il n'était pas encore
marié de son coin vous avez chacun un
compas accord compagnon grecque qui
savait que tous les deux ensemble vous
ah bah mon mari connaissait toute
l'histoire est pourquoi il est là bas il
n'a pas été frappé parce que allait lui
demander je ne sais pas parce que tu
sais quel ordinateur non l'elysée non
non j'ai été après quand j'ai arrêté le
duo j'ai rencontré deux tombés d'accord
mais la relation avec petter oui vous
étiez célibataire c'était prenant
des animateurs et si gt5 s'est passé
mais de vivre et ans de vivre c'est
quand même un peu compliqué de vue sous
l'emprise d'un homme comme ça oui c'est
difficile comment vous avez pu faire
passer des étapes et coule à ce que je
suis passé forte à l'intérieur d'accord
est très fort mais vous avez dû être
très très blessé j'étais très malade
j'ai fait une pub les chasseurs nerveuse
mais je ne les jamais montré mais ce
clown vous de vous mêmes dit il un jour
arrêts à force d'avoir été frappé
j'ai fait un arrêt cardiaque sur une
table d'opération dans ça c'est quand on
m'a emmené il m'a emmené à l'hôpital que
j'ai fait ma fausse couche ouais vous
avez perdu beaucoup de sang froid je
vais pas raconter les détails mais j'ai
fait un arrêt cardiaque le camp timon
nettoyer quoi et je me suis retrouvé
branché de partout mais jamais à
comprendre quelque chose que vous faites
la tournée
party 80 jusqu'à 80 pardon star 80 et je
tiens tiens j'ai jamais fait à cause de
vous voulez pas fait mais vous avez fait
retourner les projecteurs de savè oui et
c'est vrai qu'il vous frappez oui ben
non les producteurs de la tournée
c'était une michel leeb oui c'était
gérard louvin qui était le producteur
qui avait loupé à 85 il savait ce qui se
passait pourquoi il disait rien parce
que c'est nous regardent ils disaient
ils disaient c'est non assistance à
personne en danger où il se dispute tout
le tas d'ado qu'un homme en arabe sa
femme c'est leur problème je n'ai rien
contre jargeau 20 je ne je ne juge pas
les gens mais j'essaie de comprendre il
ya beaucoup de gens qui savaient hawtin
guizerix ii est rien il dit c'est
parfois dans des lits selon une question
ce que moi ce qui m'étonne c'est que la
presse people de l'époque type france
dimanche ici paris qui suivait beaucoup
les stars comme vous et qu'ils
méconnaissaient dans l'intimité à
l'époque il ya jamais eu un article même
un petit article est toujours tout
cacher j'ai dit qu'on s'entendait pas
qu'on se disputait souvent ce qui était
vrai mais moi jamais il m'a fait quoi
que ce soit devant témoins a par là
devant ce jour ce journaliste
photographe mais les médias gamme soit
leur s est jamais les insultes ou y
avait jamais personnes l'écoutent tête
jamais personne est aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'ils faisaient qu'est ce qui vous a
donné la force de qu'est ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui a fait déborder le
vase quand j'ai fait l'émission de
jordan voilà là là j'ai vu ça ça fait
longtemps qu'ils me détruit par tous il
m'a des tours près tous les chanteurs
des années 80 qui est dit est dit qu on
vous reçoit plus partout je suis vous
n'êtes pas manquer
que vous chantez pas qu allah il ya
quelques phrases aussi un d'abord il ya
toujours de gros soucis d'entendre mais
ça les gens ne savaient pas il s'en
foutait complètement du duo ils
voulaient tout le temps tirer la
couverture à lui oui je n'aime pas je
n'avais pas le droit de parler à
l'interview c'est vrai voilà c'est ce
qui dit aussi là vous vous dites j'étais
très amoureuse un soir je rentre je
trouve une femme dans la loge qu'il
était en train il était en train de
coucher avec je n'ai rien pu dire
voilà on vous dit en 28 ans de kayhan
nous sommes séparés 29 plus de six fois
et ça fait quatre ans qu'il m'adresse
plus la parole vous savez quand même
qu'aujourd'hui après ce qui va céder
certaines du lycée et si aujourd'hui il
va réagir eh bien il va même peut-être
porter plainte pour diffamation ah ben
oui mais moi j'ai des avocats ils
attendent à ya pas de soucis qui
viennent c'est après endroit que les
attestations j'ai tout ça s'est passé
dans les années 90 on va dire de quoi
les nourrir
après 4 5 1 2005 2015 et ce n'est rien
il ya prescription oui bien sûr mais pas
source pas sur ce qu'il advient sur sa
vie la vie qui serait il est
complètement la cap sur ce qu'il a dit
il n'a pas encore réagi après
l'interview d'une jordan et là je sais
pas s'il n'est pas encore parce que tu
ne
peux plus je me suis tue 37 ans vous
rendez compte c'est que c'est que toutes
les femmes qui ont été battues violées
toi - il ya eu un acharnement mentale et
j'avais le chantage par rapport au duo
j'étais sous contrat et je ne voulais
pas que les français seraient tous
coupés vous rendez compte vous travaillé
pendant des années pour réussir est là
parce que à cause de cet homme là il
faut tout casser moi j'aimerais peut y
avoir deux choses la première est encore
une fois je ne juge pas mais j'aimerais
comprendre aussi michel leeb nous
regardent et s'ils venaient à cette
émission un jour si gérard louvin nous
regarde si des producteurs nous regarde
si ces gens étaient témoins pourquoi ils
n'ont rien dit si une femme une femme et
frappé comme ça assure on s'est assis
sur les témoins fois on ne dit rien ils
l'ont pas vivre mon vue après bye enfin
quand on voit des avec deux femmes avec
des urbr noir et machins et que voilà
pourquoi je ne les critique pas pourquoi
ils n'ont rien dit j'aimerais bien voir
leur réponse et deuxième chose les vos
tubes qui les a écrits est ce que vous
touchez d'argent que tu sais j'ai fait
la musique dont vous toucher de l'argent
dessus mais bien sûr vous en vivez
encore mais bien sûr donc au moins
financièrement mais c'est pour ça que
j'ai tenu pour le duo place et je suis
heureuse de faire d'avoir fait ce tube
qui je suis en tournée avec la tournée
les années 80 avec une jante mais on a
su en tournée depuis quatre ans et je
suis tout seul et ça marche du tonnerre
de dieu le duo s'est arrêtée il ya dix
ans ça fait dix ans que j'ai pas parlé à
peter a peint dans les films le deuxième
fille je donne à l'avortement c'est
qu'il m'avait dit un jour vous savez les
gens toxiques n'essayez pas de les
raisonner ya rien à faire pour s'en
éloigner une question dont une question
de genre je vous aime beaucoup le savait
mais est-ce que vous est ce que vous
savez que vous pouvez choquer certaines
personnes certaines femmes battues de
dire ouvertement que vous étiez battu
mais vous avez préféré le taire tout ça
pour que la machine à cash ne s'arrête
pas à 100 c'est quand même c'est pas ça
c'est qu'il y avait beaucoup d'enjeux il
y avait quand même l'image qu'on avait
du duo on fonctionnait très fort faut
savoir que quand vous faites des
cadences de 47000 20 jours de disques ça
n'existe plus là c'est énorme on était
je pouvais pas faire un pas dans la rue
j'aurais présentait les gens mais le
rêve le rêve d'une rave du show-business
der sar est fort
c'est le rêve de sa vie et c'était le
rêve de ma vie à l'orangé est-ce que
c'était pas aussi malheureusement une
autre époque aussi où absolument pas
remettre une suffit à une femme ou une
main et j'étais à cause de ça j'étais
une femme je reconnais complètement que
j'ai été soumise et j'avais tellement
horreur que j'étais sous l'emprise sur
alors je suis
désolé m parce que vraiment vraiment
vraiment faux pas c'est un sujet qui va
te passionnés même si tôt n'a pas besoin
et j'ai promis à stone parce qu'elle est
improbable à la rendre j'ai juste une
chose à dire une seconde c'est que bien
évidemment moi mon histoire tout en la
connectant blair assassiné ma mère et ma
belle mère tina turner et acteur il ya
exactement vécu la même histoire que
vous pareil voilà et on en a parlé tout
à l'heure en loge donc effectivement
quand on est une femme battue et etc on
ne le dit pas on se tait absolument le
cash on a honte effectivement quand vous
avez un tube comme elle a eu je le
souhaite à tout le monde plus sûr un
besoin de rien envie bahamas était
incommensurable c'est énorme on n'a pas
spécialement envie de gâcher un
chef-d'oeuvre et on ferme sa gueule
ne parlez c'est sale et au jour
d'aujourd'hui
merci
irakien
[Applaudissements]
du
bon coup
là dessus
témoin cette boîte ouais 13 oh là là on
va toucher allez allez allez on enchaîne
d'animatrice toile à l'aide des deux
matches la suite
annoncé mathieu allard et non il va m'en
vais mais moi je fais chier les lâches
cheikh sèye les régimes
sans transition un peu plus léger la mer
dix jours vous êtes des détours pleure
ça te fera mais green au métier de
comédien brad me dit j'espère surtout
que tu me crois je sais que l'asie louis
d'affaires et bien signer sa plus grande
crainte c'est qu'on la prenne pour une
folle et non la pas maintenant alors
exactement